alors vous faire une interview croyances
qu'oksana le bon ne bouge pas pendant le
génial
vous avez maintenant ce qui lève le
poing comme ça c'est ceux qui sont pour
bouger par le jingle franchement alors
interview croyants soient voir en quoi
vous croyez
est ce que vous croyez que les
communistes ont vraiment changé ou que
leur profil bas et momentanée il faut
essayer de jean claude gayssot très
bonne idée ça essayer elle y fait venir
le contraire en mer en tout cas vous
pouvez faire la rotation tous les excès
de vitesse coudray je ne m'opposerai pas
dite et la natation plus vous irez vite
plus il sera content bien saviez vous me
dire ou es ce que vous croyez en vous en
moi oui je crois en moi et au départ
c'est la seule chose en ville dans
laquelle je croyais vous croyez pas en
dieu j'y croyais ou non au début de la
course vous dit dieu aide moi ou non j'y
crois constamment et surtout dans les
moments
via un peu de mal alors qu'ils croyaient
que julien clerc qu'il ya un truc très
drôle il dit toute façon moi je crois
pas en dieu et quand l'avion commence à
bouger
j'y crois pas non plus parce que dans
ces moments là tout le monde y croit
bien entendu vous vous y croyez
ti coin et j'y crois un peu plus quand
je réussis à faire des choses et chez
vous quand vous étiez petit on croyait
en dieu ou c'était mal vu ou vos parents
ils croyaient pas tout le monde croyant
en dieu on est orthodoxe en roumanie
mais on n'était pas pratiquants elle se
croyait l'effet des crèmes antirides n'y
crois pas encore mais ça va venir je
crois vous avez dit croire aux enjeux
croyez aux anges aux enfants oui moi
c'est les enfants les anges les fantômes
que des trucs gothique un peu baroque
comme ça là vous y croyez ou pas tous
ces trucs là ils font tous qu'en
roumanie tout ça en europe centrale il
soin c'était pas là dedans pas leurs
tares 106 avec un simple nom et suivant
les gens qui lancent pas les îles chargé
le leblanc alors il m'était soit de l'or
comme c'est lé presse d élevage et bien
je sois des dubois tout simplement quand
s'était procuré tout le monde ne dépend
pas de la même façon le district ans et
lubrifiants s'est fait coucher sur le
lit de jamais vous avez été sur le mid
blague la double vie de dracula
le lis de faculté
pour aller voir passer leurs vacances là
bas mais j'arrête là bien est ce que
vous croyez
ian jacobs qui va me casser la tête à la
mâchoire et ça fait mal fait est ce que
vous voyez à l'amour
l amour à l'amour toujours l'amour
toujours 3 mai à celle qui se construit
au jour le jour
plus c'est réaliste vous croyez qu'on
peut aimer sans sexe ah oui vraiment
platonique vous y croyez la fidélité
vous y croyez ça c'est fait partie du
jeu d'une amour de toujours vous croyez
à la liberté
ouais je veux y croire j'ai depuis que
je sais que je peux être libre c'est ça
que je vais essayer de faire toute ma
vie nnent l'égalité à partir du moment
où on peut être libre ouais on fait très
beau vous voyez la paternité
c'est de voir si vous êtes une brève
française en fait on croyait la liberté
à l'égalité et à la fraternité
alors je sais pas si c'est vraiment vrai
mais c'est un peu l'idéal que j'aimerais
bien dans les trois mois